[Music]
welcome back to another exciting episode
of the careful boys oh wow and i know we
have ryan has to go here but it's really
how's it going this ryan it's about that
one that's how you started that ryan so
last time we if you guys didn't see this
video we did a whole careful boys on
breakups and ryan had this mind-blowing
crazy story and we were just like i
can't believe this you guys can watch it
too um
because that's
because that one is gonna have to lead
to this one you need to know part one so
make sure you go click that part one
wait it's called off the record our
worst breakups ever yeah are our worst
breakups with a sad face uh not emoji
but typing and off camera ryan was like
i actually got more to that so we were
like oh yeah like right after the
cameras were off i remembered the rest
of what happens and then i was like damn
it it gets it gets really bad so quick
summary for those
who don't know
can we do a quick one yeah i need a tldr
i didn't watch this video quick summary
one of my earliest relationships when i
was like i think it was 18.
uh
yeah we had a really bad breakup where
um her a person died as a result of like
the chain reaction of events
um and then i just kind of lost track of
i don't know where she is today at all i
could do a summary for you okay okay you
wanna yeah let me do your part do you
want her to summarize it
ryan here here we go all right
he wanted to play a little hard to get
with the girlfriend that we was already
at with you're about to make school look
like an [ __ ] and then yeah yeah and
he's all right you know what
you're so hot i don't deserve you
because i'm a fool so you know let me
sabotage this and say [ __ ] this because
i want a woman to chase me to prove how
much she loves me right so he's like i'm
done with you and she goes no
i don't want to be done with you and
then i have to animate this it's not my
story that's why it's highly dramatized
and then she's like [ __ ]
how am i going to get them back so she
calls her cousin and the cousin said
cousin come pick me up
i need to go see the love of my life
he's about to he's breaking up with me i
need to save this
so cousin
on the way there gets into a car
accident
then
not only that cousin's family finds out
why cousin's the one that passed away by
the way oh yeah cousin's the driver
okay
now
cousin's family finds out what happened
that he was going to pick her up so they
all go confront her hey you son of a
[ __ ] we confront hurricane from him her
they don't know they don't really know
about this oh call him a son of a [ __ ]
they think it's the cousin's fault that
i mean it's the the girl's fault that
she called him for a ride yeah you
sister of a [ __ ] jesus christ an
emotional state it's like he wouldn't
have passed if he didn't call him for a
right why did you need a ride in the
first place and in the middle of the
argument
the girl
blows her mind by going crazy she hits
her head
goes into a coma what
yeah that was the reaction we had
and then so ryan is like oh no i caused
all this [ __ ] wait how did you get a
live like
like
like update as this was going on did you
hear about all this afterwards uh yeah
as it's going on oh [ __ ] did i do a good
job portraying the moment okay is this
who you want is this your emotional
siding might have been awful but that's
why you guys got to watch the first
video if you die do you want this man to
read your obituary hell yeah bro
i'm gonna do all of yours if i don't die
first that's why you ain't getting an
invitation
story is like like if rhinestones like a
black and white story yeah and if joe
painted it he made like the sun like
green i was like a colorblind person
hated this mountains were like purple
he took some liberties in the coloring
of the picture
he took some liberties yeah if it's van
gogh is colorblind
but that's that's what happened and then
now he's like yo i got more to it we're
like how can this get even crazy what a
great setup by the way because um and
and i think like
so she she's just out in the world
somewhere i have no clue where she is to
this day i have no idea what happened to
her she's not in a coma anymore right no
like so she they sent her to i don't
know it might have been a medically
induced coma i have no idea what it was
but um her parents sent her to uk to
work at like a family friend's hotel as
like a receptionist kind of as
punishment for like
yeah she was just gone and then like
years later she came back and uh she was
just kind of cuckoo and i couldn't
understand concussion yeah holy [ __ ]
yeah but i remembered that that's um the
worst thing to have happened as a result
of
me
knowing her at all
is that uh
it was all around the same time
that uh when we were kind of like on the
fritz and we were like breaking up like
cause i was always breaking up with him
[ __ ] idiot
i
me and two friends decided to go
up to where she lived and like kind of
just make a trip and um this is before
she
got in before this is before this is
before but the what happened from this
trip
lasts until today
uh
so me and two friends we were like hey
we're you know what we're gonna go up
there i'm gonna go patch some things up
with her because we're in a rocky point
um and then uh
and then my other friends are like oh
cool like we'll come along because i
want to see some
some family up
towards where she lives so we'll just
make a three-guy trip out of it'll be
cool so we drive up there um
i at this time this is like just a few
weeks before the big breakup happened
but we patched it up
and everything was cool and then
driving back me and my two friends
i was super sleepy so i was in the
passenger seat
i knocked out
this is that oh yeah this is that time
all right and then uh my other friends
in the back seat
laid across in the back seat just he
fell asleep too
our third friend who's driving
he's like the kind of guy that doesn't
want to admit when he's sleepy oh now
we'll do it yeah so
we're going down the five
pitch black it's like 3 a.m
i wake up in the middle of him going
oh [ __ ] and spinning out and then
literally right when i woke up
he's uh were just like spinning out and
rolling down the side of the like hill
oh my god and i'm like just looking
around me like what that [ __ ] looks like
it just looks like a car is getting
[ __ ] smaller and smaller and you're
just like looking holy [ __ ] is this like
a can that's being crushed on your side
of a coca-cola yeah that's exactly what
that is and then it freaking tumbles
down the hill
jeez i knock out i don't know how long
i'm out uh hill you mean you guys were
on the side of a cliff or something
something like that yeah it was like
it's like it's like an embankment you
know like how the freeway sometimes
raised oh yeah yeah so it goes you're
saying five is it because you're going
up to norcal yeah we're going we're
passing through uh
uh what's it called kern county oh yeah
so
we get to this um i come i like
literally wake up and i'm hanging upside
down in the car
and uh
when you crash like that a lot of people
don't know the seat belt kind of just
like it breaks it just gets stuck
so you're just gonna let yourself out
yeah so then like locks right because
that's spinning mechanism and i like
while i'm still upside down i look to
the side and my friend's not even in the
car the guy that was driving oh he's not
even there i don't even know if he like
oh my god bro yeah so i'm just hanging
upside down and then i eventually like
break the rest of the seat belt i don't
even think about my dude in the back
seat i just get out of the car were you
in passenger yeah it's passenger and i'm
just like you can't see [ __ ] but then i
can hear the my friend who was driving i
could hear him in the distance like
yelling
and i thought he was like hurt or
something
and he's not
he's he's just running around in circles
and he's
like yelling to himself and he's
freaking out and he's just like he's
like oh [ __ ] oh my god like he's just
like like kind of like i guess he's just
getting into that mode he's in shock
yeah yeah and i i kind of have like a
weird
state where like when things like that
happen to me i don't really go into
fight or flight i'm just kind of like
whoa you know and i go up to it i'm like
dude calm the [ __ ] down like what's
wrong with you and he's just like he's
like oh i [ __ ] i killed him i killed
him bro i [ __ ] killed him and i guess
like it had been some time like he had
already been kind of like around and
like surveying he thought we were both
[ __ ] dead oh and then um
and then i go back
and then um my dude
in the back seat he's sticking out
halfway
on the upside-down car
and then i go over to him and he's
conscious and i'm like i just like go up
to him and i just hold him and i'm just
like kind of like looking at his current
state
and he's just like
dude i can't feel my legs bro
[ __ ]
and then i'm thinking like
legs but also he doesn't know that like
in the accident uh his throat got slit
oh
[ __ ] it's just
it's coming out so you're you're holding
on i'm trying to stop i'm trying to stop
his throat his throat from bleeding out
at the same time that he's just like
dude i can't i can't like move or
anything so then like holy [ __ ] i don't
know what the [ __ ] to do and this other
dude's freaking out so it's just me and
him and i'm just like
i'm just look look at this scene i'm
just like dude i don't know i don't know
what to do man like i don't know i have
no idea
were there any people stopping for you
there was nothing out there it was 3 am
kern county 5 freeway there's nothing so
then
i just did my best and there's no cell
phones back then right
uh cause it's like what 18 19. not well
or maybe an old school phone all my [ __ ]
i think my wallet everything flew out
the window so i didn't have anything so
um
so i tied him up or something and then
like i ran to the um to the the freeway
which was like i had to climb up the
hill and went to the freeway and my
other dude's still [ __ ] going nuts
were like on the side of the mountain
yeah and then i climbed up i went to the
road i was like three trucks went by
didn't stop and i was like please stop
and then like finally a trucker guy
stops
and then he's just freaking out on how i
look and cause you're covered in blood
or what yeah i had no idea that like
there was glass in my head oh my god bro
he thought that i was like i'm like no
no i'm like dude there's something
[ __ ] way crazier yeah and so today's
video is brought to you by babble babble
is the number one language learning app
they got over 10 million subscribers to
the app and downloads it's pretty
awesome and if you're out there trying
to learn a new language i highly
recommend this and it's because it's not
just some like boring app where you're
just sitting there listening to a neck
lecture you're not like being bored like
it's a stupid it's a stupid flash cards
or whatever right babel is actually
made by real language experts over 100
exactly over like 100 right and they
help develop this app so it's not like
bobby hill's mom trying to teach you
espanol
yeah and they have over 14 different
languages you could check out like
italian spanish
german and they even have speech
recognition technology so that you can
speak to it and it'll correct your
enunciation so you actually get better
through practice where's the bano that's
bathroom baby which is half english
and my favorite thing about it it's
quick 15 minute lessons at a time so
it's easy to fit it in during the break
you can do it on a jog you can do it
while you're cleaning around the house
so it's very easy and digestible and you
can break down a lot of course material
in short amount of time
so if you want to check it out learn a
new language for this year's new year's
resolution go to babel.com that's
babbel.com and use the promo code off
the record because right now they got a
sick deal you get six months for the
price of three that's babble
b-a-b-b-e-l.com with promo code off the
record to get six months for the price
of three
using his truck radio he was able to
call uh
paramedics and stuff
and then uh holy [ __ ] and then the
paramedics got there really [ __ ] fast
like thank goodness i don't know how
like they got their show i i was able to
go back to to my friend and i was like
don't worry like they're coming they're
coming and he's just like fading out and
i'm like dude he's not gonna make it man
and then
the paramedics uh get there and then
they're like the um immediately they're
like hey go wait on the road side of the
road like we're gonna have someone look
at you whatever and then i go over there
to the side of the road and i'm just
like i'm on the road with like a
different uh emt
and i'm watching like what they're doing
to my friend and then i just see them uh
throw like a sheet over them
and i'm like oh [ __ ] like dude didn't
make it like i was like
i couldn't believe it and then the other
dude's just like being consoled because
he's just like totally like
jibber-jabber yeah he's in tool shot
so i'm just watching both of these
things go down uh a helicopter comes and
they uh they take him and i was like
you're getting a helicopter like to i
thought he's like he passed away and
then they were like no we're just
covering because it's cold like he's
still he's still like
he's still receptive so they airlift him
over to like kern county medical
and then um
and then i go to the same place but in
an ambulance and then they think that
like i don't know why they thought my
neck was broken so they put me in the
thing
and then they like cut off all my
clothes and [ __ ]
and then i end up in a hospital bed
right next to my friend
who um who had his his [ __ ] cut and then
um
i can't see him i could just hear what
they're saying about him on the other
side of the curtain oh that must be
[ __ ] and they're just saying like
they're saying stuff like hey like uh
we're gonna have i just we want you know
we're gonna have to cut a hole into your
um
into your skull
because they had to hold i guess he had
severed his um
uh
vertebrae or something or spine
and then um
they were gonna have to drill into his
head and hold it together and it was i
was hearing all these like little bits
of details and [ __ ]
and then um
finally i like after i went through my
treatments and everything and i got
patched up i got out of the hospital and
then um not out of the hospital but out
of that room where a doctor was talking
to me and he was like
um
he was like hey uh
his his mother is on the way
do you want to tell him or do you want
me to to talk to them like about what
happened i was like what do i have to
say like what's his current state
and um the doctor's like your friend has
about
a 13 chance of recovery
he's paralyzed from the torso
down yeah and then i'm like i gotta
[ __ ] say that to his mom
yeah
and then so uh his mom gets there and
then um so does my friend eris like
who's like a question guy with me and he
gets there and then she just like hugs
me and she's like what happened and i'm
like
i gotta i just have to tell her like
yeah he's damn that's a lot of [ __ ] you
had to do man how old were you when this
happened as 18. and this happened before
the last story you said yeah and where
was it what was the driver buddy in all
of this was he just like he was in
another um that's a bad that gets bad
too but he was in another area of the
hospital because he wasn't he barely got
it hurt at all he was fine uh and then
uh so i had to tell her and then i and
then they're like hey you can come see
him now and i go in there and i see him
worst thing i've ever seen he's got
these like
things drilled into his head to hold it
together oh he has they had to knock all
his teeth out so they can put the tube
down so that he could breathe oh my gosh
whoa
and he's just like
he could talk and he could look at me
and i was like dude
you don't look too good man like it
doesn't sound like it's gonna go well
and
i was it was the worst thing to have to
have a conversation with someone like
that and then uh
the other dude
[ __ ] made me so goddamn angry once i
saw him and he got out of his area of
the hospital and we met up
i didn't know what he was gonna say like
or anything and he says some i can't
[ __ ] remember exactly what he said
but it's along the lines of like
dude that was crazy wasn't it oh and i
just want to [ __ ] murder him on the
spot dude yeah like i had never wanted
to kill somebody and i was like i can't
[ __ ] believe that's your attitude
does he even know what happened to the
he i think
yeah i think what happened is he went
into a weird mental state of denial of
everything oh [ __ ] yeah because um
so after this night
and i get back home
um
basically my friend spent a about a year
living in the hospital
doing therapy recovery on like his
paralysis and uh my other friend
just completely uh
hid he just hid like you mean he didn't
come and visit or none of that [ __ ] he
avoided us completely because i think
his family was like no don't talk to
them because they're gonna make you pay
for this like they're gonna sue what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] family and he just [ __ ]
bounced and and he just like disappeared
and i i man
so then i remembered um
like er like everyone was like oh the
driver had to be responsible for what
happened and everything but
we could we just couldn't get to him i
would send him these bills which are
supposed to go to him and his family
would just throw him away
and then
did you have any physical damage from
the whole car no i just lost like i'm
bald on the top of my head from the
glass like you could never see it but a
lot of places are just like yeah i just
have like little cuts like if i were to
buzz my head it would look like lines
and [ __ ] yeah holy [ __ ] and then and
then i had a the air bag took out a
piece of my i had to get it grafted but
i lost like this part of my skin
so i had to get that replaced
so your buddy in the back seat who was
knocked out he wasn't wearing a seat
belt he wasn't wearing so you just laid
down on the he wasn't wearing a seat
belt and so like when you're not wearing
seatbelt and something's rolling yeah
just like you get the worst of it
and then so he's in the hospital for
about a year
and probably the worst the worst thing
about him being stuck in that hospital
and he can't move and he's um it's not
that it's the fact that like when i
visited him
i was like hey man like how's
he he was like just slowly getting
better i'm like dude how's it how's it
going and he said
he said the worst thing is that um
his parents were going through a divorce
and he had to like or they had gone
through it and now they're fighting
about what's happening to him
in front of him in the room and he can't
get the [ __ ] out of there
jesus like he said that's the worst
thing that's bad dude damn and even i
didn't visit him as much as i should
have because i couldn't face
what i [ __ ] because it was my idea to
like go out there because because i was
doing my [ __ ] usual breakup with my
ex and i'm like can we go like it's my
[ __ ] idea so it's like my guilt was
there too yeah but like and i i couldn't
visit him as often as i wanted to i was
just i felt so [ __ ] guilty
and then um
so he so after that year like he's now
like it moves up to like being in a
wheelchair and he's doing like
incrementally well and then he moves
over to crutches the year after that and
then he moves over to kane and then he
actually uh fully recovered today and
now is a therapist for kids that are
going through the same thing that's wild
you mean fully recovered like he could
walk
in
what yeah so he had a 13 chance of
walking again yeah 13 and he was able to
walk again he had a 13 chance of any
improvement wow and now he's like that's
why i gamble guys
riding on that thirteen percent
and this dude is like a [ __ ] good guy
too oh so you know this guy too yeah
that's what i'm saying oh [ __ ] this is
this is i know this i've heard this
story but i've never heard it in detail
and
he's devoted his life to helping people
recover like from anything anything
physical but isn't that like a [ __ ]
movie though right like like you go
through something so traumatic like that
when you're so young and then it shapes
your whole life to be helping other
people in the same situation like that's
that's poetic dude that is it's it's
almost like he was meant to be that
angel to like yeah it's an unfortunate
situation but now he can help so many
other people that he's like dude i've
been through it too yeah yeah what
happened to the ship back i i hope it's
my i've never heard this story about the
[ __ ] back dude who didn't show up for
y'all though that's that's what makes me
go what did you get run over by a bus or
something no i think like after so many
years like by the third year and my
friend was already in a wheelchair
uh we would like uh he came he came to
the house when we were celebrating like
the three year anniversary of his
recovery and stuff wow
and i think like we me and my friend
both agreed like yeah he just went
through some like mental [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] in the head now but whatever but
he's like if that's how he deals with it
fine you know you recovered i recovered
let it be what it is like we're not
gonna what are we gonna get out of them
you know so we're still friends and like
we'll still meet up to this day and just
you know be cool so he never meant uh
mentally recovered from that incident so
it got worse and worse and then now he
just lives in a delusional world i think
it's just easier to not give him [ __ ]
about it because it's you're not going
to get any is there any
is there still like lingering feelings
or is there closure or like you know are
you guys like on the same page at all
it's like
i don't know i personally like when i
think about it for me i'm i still feel
really guilty
i think it's nice to know that like my
friend entered that world of like being
an uh therapist and getting and going to
school for that and finishing and now
he's this hero for like other people
yeah that i think i want to use that as
like a way for me to feel better about
it but i don't like i still feel like it
was my [ __ ] idea yeah yeah if i just
never said if i didn't have a tumultuous
relationship and let you be the
collateral damage of that like and you
did it again afterwards
that's why this is so [ __ ] crazy
joe didn't let him have that moment
he's like remember you did this twice
[ __ ] but you know like it's so much time
has passed and so much good has happened
in his life that like we we look at it
like oh like man like what a blessing
that we you know we're able to still
come back from that and do anything but
that's wild back to [ __ ] back right
so what was that two years this this is
a joke
have you healed yet that was like a
month before
a month yeah it was like
he was still in the hospital by the time
i that the breakup story that i had
actually happened he was still i mean
that must have been a just crazy
emotional rollercoaster for you it was a
lot of [ __ ] within a month yeah were you
like depressed later that year or no how
are you able to handle it i think it's
just like because i was so young and
like
i just thought that everything was
dramatic like oh my impression of the
world was that it was always like this
yeah it's supposed to be because it
happened like if it happened to me now i
would be a [ __ ] wreck but like back
then when i was like this kid that was
always
like my life was always filled with like
extremes yeah i was like oh this is just
the [ __ ] world you know
like nothing just normally happens but i
mean yeah all those things it's no one's
it's not your fault like it's like dude
you're just doing young boy [ __ ] which
is like hey i want to go see my
girlfriend to break up with her or
whatever like yeah that's who would have
thought yeah i mean you can't all those
things are you're not the only person
that broke broke up with someone on the
phone and then they're like yo i need a
ride to go see my boyfriend like that
[ __ ] happens all the [ __ ] time yeah
the i mean the root of it still is like
if you're sleepy let someone know that's
basically like the root of hell yeah how
to not get into an accident like that
but
but still it's like you can't help but
like
feel like weird when you kind of stoked
everyone's fire about doing it in the
first place
then it's kind of like
i always wondered how much if anybody
secretly was blaming me you know i mean
but
there's three people in the car right
everybody could have
stayed up to [ __ ] keep the driver up
the driver could have spoke up and been
like i'm tired guys like there's so many
things that there's a lot of variables
it's not just the motive of let's have a
road trip that's the blame of everything
yeah yeah but you know as a rational
human being
someone that has empathy for other
people's situations i think it is
natural to be like yeah i feel guilty
about it i think that's normal this
never would have happened if i started
it yeah and if you didn't think that i'd
be like you're kind of [ __ ] crazy
right
just deflecting the blame exactly and
it's like yeah you took your
responsibility for whatever happened and
one thing like what joe said it's not
right i think it's anyone i could
[ __ ] invite you to lunch tomorrow and
we'll on our way to in and out something
can happen too that's you know like and
i could be like if i just never invited
him to get that double double yeah god
damn yeah that's a lot and you know him
so you know like how it things didn't
turn out dismally like it it did
it ignited something that maybe
otherwise wouldn't have happened yeah
that it's a very strong positive
but it's
i never talked to him about like this
part but it's still hard to look at him
and like be fully happy for what he's
achieving
because i'm i'm a little bit like
there's a piece of you when i sort of
forced you to have to make the best of
this yeah
he's doing
[ __ ] phenomenal things with live
better than many things that i would
consider i do so i think i think it's
okay
to to
at the very least be able to look at him
and be like yo this is this is uh some
higher purpose [ __ ] it's really what i
mean yeah for real yeah it is it's i'm
proud of them and it's hard like every
step of the way as he achieves more and
more it's like
it's good but maybe i think i'm the only
person like
in any of our lives it's just like
it congrats but also
yeah you feel something there for sure
for sure and i've also seen you with him
at every moment highest and lowest of
your entire life so i also feel like you
know things happen and you can't control
everything but like you've always been
there for him so he's he's also
quest group like he's quite screwed
he's awesome
but it's hard when
that happens so early in our lives that
pretty much everyone in our circle has
only ever seen him with a limp or with
like
they don't know that we look at him i
still see him the way like
over a decade ago when
his me he had to relearn how to do
everything his mannerisms the way he
speaks the way he like gestures it's
completely different today and it's like
he's like oh marion and you guys served
when he got hurt right he heard us oh
did he did he i don't think he did i
thought he was like spraying his ankle
then he sprained his ankle or marcus
yeah yeah so what were you saying all
right and then he had to like relearn
how to dance with the limp
was it marcus i think he just never
dances in the rest of the film yeah he
does it he stays injured doesn't he that
there was a guy that got injured and he
had to like relearn how to dance a guy
does get injured he he never dances
again i don't think um well this story
is better i think he knows the movie too
you guys served well if he's a part of
quest he dances again right
no he's he's he's in quest kind of just
as the honorary member well he's he he
did used to dance
before
like we we used to practice together
now he's he's just a therapist like he
takes care of us you know like so he's
like the team like but he's physically
fair yeah yeah he's family all the way
sure that's tight yeah but yeah it's
like it's it's hard to know that like
man like i still can't unsee the old
i saw like you know like when when you
when you know someone and then you see
them relearn every physicality they've
ever known yeah it's a trip like that
you know
that's crazy yeah well thanks for
sharing man thank you very much that was
a really crazy yeah pretty sure everyone
else watching too is like not only like
in shock but then inspired by what your
homie did yeah you know it's a it's a
very good story i think like
for people that he helps out too because
it's like he came back from 13
yeah paralysis from the torso down
like he was just a body in a bed for a
year and to think about how severe the
accident was and the position that he
was in i think most people would have
died yeah most people just give up dude
that's scary to me you know they would
have died in that accident so it's why
try it and it was a very slow long
recovery it's like
a year in a bed a year in a wheelchair a
year on crutches a year on a cane now he
has no cane and he just walks and does
his thing and
you know good for him bro yeah good for
him he's a good dude but that was
again like when i remembered that that
was so deeply connected to that bad
breakup story i'm like this is
eons way heavier than yeah [ __ ] my
relationship [ __ ] this is like give me
teary-eyed bro
yeah i think the appropriate outro song
is beyonce survivor
we can't play that we'll we'll get we'll
get the we'll get the challenge
[Music]
[Music]
you